whether you're a ceo founder or c-suite
executive employee investor sales person
it's very
important to know what's going to happen
to the u.s economy under a joe
biden administration so in today's
episode we're going to cover the
following things number one
how his policies are going to affect
different industries and i mean every
industry
energy hollywood finance we're going to
cover it all gold
we'll cover all that stuff number two
who is potentially going to be in his
administration who's he choosing
it's important for you to know because
some of them is going to impact your
industry
next what is he going to be doing in the
first 100 days what can he do with the
tax laws
what can he change about tax loss what
can he not do those are all things we
need to
at the end i'm going to share with you
my next five plus moves
if i were you
so stick around to the very end because
you're going to get a pdf with
everything i talk about in this video to
talk to your friends family co-workers
boss board whoever it may be but before
we get into everything i think it's very
important we
preface what is really going on right
now so right now the score is
279 to 217 biden bidens got the lead
although
georgia and arizona doing a recount by
hand by the time you watch this the
results may be out already
you know the house dems own 218 to i
believe 202
i want to say the dems lost five seats
the republicans
took six seats on the senate side
republicans now have
50 to 48 they took on alaska so they're
not 50 to 40 with two seats left
when it comes down to senate which is
going to be the biggest biggest runoff
we've had with 200 million dollars
being spent in georgia and these are the
candidates you're looking at right now
for senate you're looking at
democratic raphael warnock going against
kelly lefler republican then you're
looking at john ossoff democrat going
against senator
david perdue this is a red state the
last time georgia had a democratic
senator was in 2000
zell miller so this is very important
for a lot of things i cover because
the one and a half trillion dollar tax
cut that uh biden may want to get rid of
he needs the senate i talk to my
accountants
my cpas a lot of different people they
can't do this but if it's 50 50
50 seats dems 50 said republicans the
person that becomes the
tiebreaker vote is kamala harris so it's
very very important what's going on
we're not going to know
uh those two seats until january that's
why 200 million dollars of money is
being spent
republicans are going there democrats
are going there that have nothing to do
with the state
everybody's campaigning there and last
but not least one of the things that
could also take place is
say trump ends up conceding and losing
he may want to
have a negotiation taking place so he
could be pardoned for any future issues
so they cannot just come back and keep
them in court for a while
a lot of these things are on the table
uh that is currently taking place so
let's set that part aside let's set that
part aside
let's talk about what biden's plans are
in his first 100 days
so there are a lot of different things
on his mind but the number one thing on
his mind is the hand link of chronovirus
and he brought on board
the chief of chronovirus task force
michael osterham
who uh he has suggested to biden that it
is a good idea for us to shut down the
economy for
four to six weeks so remember this four
to six week shutdown
many times can lead to a 90-day shutdown
because if we go four to six weeks
and the economy is not still recovering
you have to know that we may say
let's go another four weeks if we
already gone six weeks let's go four
more weeks
and i can easily turn into 90 days which
leads to the stimulus package what's he
gonna do because if you're gonna shut
down the economy for four to six weeks
what are you gonna be doing so here's
where he's at with the stimulus
he has ideas but nothing is specific for
example the cares act that trump had
he has something similar to that that he
wants to announce which is
helping out 160 million people paying
him 1200 a month but he doesn't know the
exact number yet because he's got to get
it past
senate and the house number two
extension of unemployment benefits which
we had 600
a week for unemployment provided by many
different states and the temporary
relief provided additional 300
a week for six weeks biden has no
specific plan for that he just says i'm
going to do something
like that the next one is bigger monthly
social security checks he wants to
increase
the monthly social security checks that
the current beneficiaries are getting
200 more he wants to put 200 more to
that the other potential measures he
could take is more money to small
businesses
emergency sickly for everyone who needs
it fiscal relief to states
he also wants to do no out-of-pocket
money for covet-19 testing treatment
and an eventual vaccine so you're not
going to be paying for that stuff that's
what he wants to pass
so now the question becomes can he do
all of this stuff by himself without
needing the senate
or the republicans to support it he will
use wartime legislation known as the
defense production act dpa to compel us
businesses to make personal protective
equipment
medical supplies ventilators and
whatever else the us needs to tackle the
pandemic
biden also has set out plans to increase
unemployment insurance
send more direct payments to struggling
americans forgive some student loans and
provide more aid to small businesses
but here's a big but biden will probably
need
republican support for major stimulus
package and
after running up the biggest budget
deficit in history under trump
the republicans have begun talking about
the necessity
to balance the books once more the other
issue that's on top of his list
is climate change biden himself said
number one issue facing humanity is
climate change so the whole paris
climate accord
they're going back at it with 174 other
countries he's also introduced a climate
change proposal for 1.7 trillion dollars
in federal spending over the next 10
years
so that's where he stands with climate
change another thing that is working
very aggressively is the minimum wage
topic you see a lot of different states
florida just announced
we're going to 15 minimum wage by 2026
which means
they can increase the minimum wage a
dollar every year but biden
wants to make the federal minimum wage
from 720
to 15 dollars that is 720 to 15
so all the restaurants that the waiters
waitresses get paid
720 minimum wage plus tips their cost is
going to double wait you see what's
going to happen to the restaurant
and hospitality industry here at minimum
we look at it so he will be facing and
challenging
the republicans to raise federal minimum
wage to 15 bucks an hour
another thing is he's continuously
talked about he wants to give two years
of
college-free community college to every
single american family
that wants to go to college but it's a
little bit more technical than that let
me kind of unpack it for you so you know
how this is going to work out biden
could wipe out fifty thousand dollars of
student debt per borrow without congress
here are three
other areas where he can help the
struggling u.s economy
even with a gop-controlled senate here's
why this matters
both senator chuck schumer and senator
elizabeth warren unveiled a proposal for
the next president to cancel up to 50
thousand dollars in student loan debt
the president united states has the
power to broadly cancel student loan
debt
help close the racial wealth gap and
give a big boost to families and our
economy
warren said in a statement in september
it's time to use the existing authority
and permanently
improve the lives of tens of millions of
americans now this depart
biden has proposed forgiven ten thousand
dollars in student led for borrowers
as part of coronavirus relief package
nearly 42 million americans owe a total
of 1.7 trillion dollars
why does this matter why does elizabeth
warren matter because you're going to
find out here in a minute if she is
going to be part of his
cabinet the next one's pretty obvious
affordable health care ak obamacare
he's going to bring that back and
probably try to get it even to be more
extensive than what it was before
because obama was a person he was a vp
ii
and obama campaign for him there's got
to be a certain level of loyalty to
bring that back up so expect that to
come back around
in the first 100 days as far as travel
bans go many of those are going to go
away starting with abandoning trump's
travel ban on mostly muslim countries
that's going to go away and next one is
taxes he is planning on getting rid of
all of the 1.5 trillion dollar
trump's tax plan that he unveiled in
2017.
biden wants to get away with it now what
does this really mean to you i'm going
to explain
every one of them for you so you can
kind of get an idea trump's tax plan if
you look at the screen right now
he lowered corporate taxes to 21 biden
wants to increase it to 28.
income and payroll taxes 37 under trump
biden wants to increase the top line to
52 small business taxes went down to
29.6
biden wants to increase that to 39.6
capital gains and dividend taxes
went down to 23.8 percent he will be
increasing that
to 43.4 percent so to concern with a lot
of business owners private equity vc
you're going to see what's going to
happen to them here in a minute because
they're going to be affected by this by
as far as industries goes it's the
following what's going to happen with
taxes and
can biden with an executive order go
ahead and revert back
all of the tax cuts that trump gave and
here's the answer the answer is
no but there's a technical no he may not
be able to get rid of all of it this is
why georgia matters so much with the two
senate seats the races that's going the
race that's going on
it's very very important but he can make
adjustments meaning
if himself you know if some of the guys
on republican side come back and listen
28 maybe we're not going to do 20
maybe we raise the 21 to 25 they may
then negotiate
to change some of those numbers but it
may not come back up so there may be
some kind of negotiation going on
in 2021 but if he wants to cut all of it
and get rid of it
he's going to need to send it so
georgia's going to matter more than ever
before
this is why they're spending 200 million
dollars in georgia
so let's go through the cabinet real
quick these are just some of the names
that's been thrown around we can decide
for yourself whether you like it or not
but this is what he's looking at right
now
as far as cabinet goes secretary of
state he's looking at susan rice obama's
national security advisor or anthony
bilkin
obama's former deputy secretary of state
and deputy national security adviser so
he's looking at some of the guys that
were under obama so
what obama had is what biden's planning
on having as far as secretary of defense
goes he's looking at michelle florene
which is hillary's pick in 2016 former
under secretary of defense
or johnson obama's department of
homeland security head which is again
you're getting what hillary and obama
had as far as the secretary of defense
goes as far as attorney general goes
he's looking at sally yates career
federal prosecutor she's the one who
refused to defend trump's executive
order banning travelers
from several muslim majority countries
so you know where she's what role she's
going to play
he's also looking at senator doug jones
from alabama or tom perez
who's a dnc chairman now as far as the
secretary of treasury goes this is where
it gets interesting
number one on his list you ready senator
elizabeth warren financial industry
brace for impact now let's look at
secretary homeland security he's looking
at lisa monaco obama's homeland security
advisor or alejandro
mayorkas former director of u.s
citizenship and immigration services
this could be a lot of different
possibilities for the dreamers this next
one's very important secretary of labor
you know who he's looking at
bernie sanders you know what bernie
sanders wants to do
race federal minimum wage to 15 bucks an
hour so again
brace for impact next one is secretary
of commerce which he's choosing
i believe it may be meg whitman which is
a former ceo of quibby that just went
out of business they raised 1.8 billion
but she did a great job at ebay she took
the company i believe from four million
a year to eight billion a year
and from uh 30 employees to 15 000
employees and she ran for governor in
the state of
you know as a republican in state of
california so she's actually not a bad
pick to have
as secret secretary commerce as far as
secretary of energy goes he is looking
at ernest muniz
and elizabeth sherwood randall both on
obama's cabinet for energy the challenge
is monis is tied to fossil fuels so
progressives
may not think he's far left enough to
push the agenda that they're trying to
push with biden then you have
administrator of the environmental
protection agency mary nichols is number
one on that list they call her the queen
of green
uh california air regulator who she is
this is very important because if they
want to do anything with climate change
or the 1.7 trillion dollar plan over the
next 10 years she's probably going to be
pushing that
and spearheading that project last but
not least head of veteran first he's
looking at somebody that made a big name
for themselves in this last
election and that's mayor pete budecich
he was in the military before himself
so he has experience and he has strong
opinions so that's gonna be who he's
putting there
for head of veteran affairs so before i
get into the next part if you're getting
value so far about what i'm talking
about in the episode push that thumbs up
button and the subscribe button
if you did so i appreciate you for doing
so let me get right into it so
industries how our industry is going to
be affected under a biden administration
let's talk about airlines so airlines
were taking a big hit
pfizer announced this vaccine stock
explodes some 20 30 40
for some of these companies some were
talking american airlines may go out of
business but what's going to happen
under biden here's a few challenges that
they're going to be facing
number one biden is all about the mask
and he's all about social distancing and
a lot of the airlines recently have been
getting away
with being able to sit next to each
other with a mask on
biden may enforce six feet social
distancing
so flights may not be full meaning you
cannot have another person sitting next
to you that's a stranger
unless if it's your family and that's
going to take a big hit for airlines
the other one is the fact that what
they're doing right now
if by any chance these airlines start
kind of hurting
and their numbers drop off here he and
his administration may force
for some of them to acquire one another
so the airline industry could be a very
fickle i know these guys go on very
small margins three and a half percent
the airline industry is not going to be
looking good under by the administration
next automobiles this one's going to be
interesting because you know he's he's
all about
climate change and they're going to want
to bring back given tax credits to
buyers who buy electric cars
so we're talking about it's going to
benefit tesla probably volkswagen gm
ford and any other manufacturer that's
making cars
that are electric however all the other
cars that are oil
burning cars they're probably going to
take a big hit so watch that very
closely you will see some companies
go like this and some are going to take
massive hits cannabis industry could be
very ecstatic based on some of the
things that biden administration is
working on meaning you have the states
act and a morse act that currently puts
cannabis as a controlled substance but
if those
go away then you're talking about the
tax code 280e if you're in the cannabis
industry you know what i'm talking about
that allows the entrepreneur the
business owner
to write off their operating expenses on
a monthly basis which means their
profit's going to go higher
and they can net more it's all going to
be good if those things go together
it's removed as a controlled substance
it benefits the cannabis industry so
let's talk about casinos and gambling so
one thing we do know is the fact that
online gambling
and online betting is on fire one of the
fastest growing
uh segments of casinos right now it's
not even close what they're doing
last year the trump administration
wanted to reinforce the 1961
wire act which kind of hurt the online
gambling industry
and biden's not for it he's totally
against it so
the online gambling industry may do well
under abiding administration however if
they're gonna still shut down for
another four to six weeks which is
chief of task force for coronavirus is
suggesting to do
the physical casinos may take a hit
online gambling may do very well
but he may give a stimulus to the union
that's dealing with casinos so again
a lot going on there but it's something
to think about if you're in that
industry
so manufacturers which is a big part of
the economy has taken a hit due to the
tariffs that trump put against china
and some of these other countries
obviously biden is
a little more pro-china than uh trump as
a matter of fact not a little bit more a
lot more
he's always done business with china
he's probably gonna
remove a lot of those sanctions towards
china which means
boeing honeywell a lot of those
companies ge
that is doing business out there they're
probably going to continue so those
tariffs
are going to help a lot of the
manufacturing company that we have in
america
it's going to help us short-term
long-term
is just going to strengthen china so
next one is restaurants which
restaurants are not in a good place
right now for many different reasons
especially what happened with the
pandemic and they were shut down
75 50 25 you know what i'm talking about
they had to put the plexiglass a lot of
restaurants couldn't afford to put the
plexiglas
following all the guidelines the
restaurant industry is going to take a
massive hit here's why
he is thinking about enforcing a 15
minimum wage bernie sanders elizabeth
warren you can't already see that taking
place
if he does again we talked about this
before restaurants typically pay minimum
wage to their waiters
and waitresses and they make money on
the tip so they make 720.
now restaurants have to raise that 720
to 15 bucks which it may not be a big
deal in a big market like miami or new
york or chicago
or dallas or san francisco or l.a but
it's gonna hurt the restaurant business
and the rest
of america that's not a big market they
can't afford to take it to 15 bucks
they will and then at the same time
shutting down and doing that part
in 2019 the numbers came back on what is
the cost the operating expense on what
it is to run a business
for restaurants 31 is their labor that's
more than the amount of money they spend
restaurants on food 31
so imagine that 31 doubles if you take
minimum wage from 720 to 15 bucks
restaurants are going to take a massive
massive hit
if they continue to wake they're going
right now with some of biden's ideas
retailers this one's pretty easy i mean
this is a non-essential industry so at
any point they can shut them down and
not go to work and
to take them from 720 to 15 bucks a lot
of retailers are going to take a big hit
with us raising it and shutting down so
it's going to be a double whammy for the
retail industry
so so the next one is pharmaceuticals
which you know he has said that he's
going to go back and renegotiate prices
with these big pharma companies and say
hey you know
you gotta achieve you're making too much
money but i think it's a lot of talk
with this one because
obamacare only helped those guys so to
come out with this when we
know when obamacare came out costs 140
as an employer myself
i was getting health insurance for
everybody like this insurance went up so
if that comes back around at the levels
that he wants it
and he says he's going to go negotiate
with big pharma i just don't
see that happening so i don't see a lot
changing on the big pharma industry
so now let's talk about the big
technology companies we start off with
google or alphabet
they're going to take a very big hit
here's why so you know
early days when the internet first came
out there was something called section
230 which prevented these
big technology social media companies
google companies
from being sued for what the user says
so imagine i put up something
and i say something and i have something
that's inaccurate
section 230 protected youtube and google
from saying
i didn't do it our users did it i didn't
do it somebody on facebook posted it i
didn't do it somebody said it on twitter
biden wants to enforce and get rid of
section 230 to put the liability
on the company which means a company
like google
youtube facebook may have to hire a
whole new department
to approve watches to approve every
video before it gets uploaded on youtube
so imagine if that happens number one
the speed of getting
approved video that's gonna take a long
time and number two it's gonna get the
interest away from people that want to
create content so they could go away so
this could really throw a wrench into
alphabet
and google he's not going to be as
friendly to them it seems like as obama
was
a few years ago when he was the
president so the next one is amazon
the thing with amazon is under every
administration it's just nobody's been
able to do it going up against uh
bezos and i don't know if he's gonna be
able to do it or not uh amazon's
probably the closest thing to monopoly
that we have in america today although
walmart growing helps amazon and some of
these other guys growing helps amazon
but
he may want to get in the way because
amazon is the number one
product they have products but they're
also sellers so they're working on both
ends and that kind of gives them an
edge and a lack of accountability and
somewhat of an accountability
so he may make it very hard for amazon
he may not i don't know it's going to be
very tough to go against amazon
but he may want to do it so we'll see so
let's talk about apple even though tim
cook
under trump's administration had a good
relationship going out even though
politically
they fully disagree this may actually be
a good thing for apple because biden
again what he does with china he cuts
those tariffs
regulation opens it up apple cannot
produce their phones in china for
cheaper cost
bigger margins for themselves that's
going to be beneficial to them and at
the same time a lot of apples engineers
that they were recruiting
it made it easier when they had the h-1b
visas but trump made it a little bit
harder
i have a feeling biden's going to make
easier to get those visas which means
more engineers could come and work for
apple
so it could actually end up being a good
thing for apple again it goes to china
so if those tariffs open
up the chip maker industry 400 billion
dollars a year intel you got a lot of
different companies
that are making it in china they're
going to benefit from it but at the same
time the sanctions that trump put on
huawei
biden may loosen up he may eliminate all
the sanctions with huawei and huawei was
a
i don't know if you remember a few years
ago everything we heard about on daily
basis was
huawei maybe another company may be
hearing about on a daily basis again if
biden loosens up those tariffs hollywood
let's talk hollywood so hollywood's
going to have an interesting time
because
when's the last time you saw a new movie
coming out that you were excited about
honestly when's the last time you
watched the movie like oh my gosh
it's a big actor not happening right now
because they're not working right so
hollywood's really taking a big hit with
covid but
biden's policies could absolutely hurt
hollywood because of social distancing
because of all these other parameters
and guidelines you have to follow
so they may double or triple the cost of
these
you know studios that are trying to
produce a movie so again and then the
four to six weeks so hollywood's still
going to take a hit
for as long as uh biden's administration
wants to believe in the shutdown
hollywood's gonna take a big hit
social media this one's interesting
because we're talking about facebook
twitter youtube so
it's gonna be not good for content
creators because
facebook and twitter every time they
went against trump or they did something
that
they wanted to remove a post trump from
the top is like censorship censorship
censorship censorship
and they had to go to court constantly
defend themselves and it was always
these embarrassing things you were
seeing on
interviews and being held and all this
stuff it's not going to happen under
biden biden's going to be a little bit
more lenient which they're going to have
more
ability to go and say we want to delete
this and the president's going to say
you have the right to do so that may
take place and on top of that
biden's probably not going to tweet as
often as twitter is ok as
often as trump is which means that could
hurt twitter stock because
so many people those who love them those
who are in the middle
and those who hate them simply log on on
twitter every day to see what trump has
to say
and if trump goes from tweeting 10 times
a day 20 times a day to once or twice a
day under biden
i don't know i don't know if twitter
wins especially if trump just decides to
go to a completely different place
twitter may actually take a hit the next
couple years i think facebook google
youtube their backing is going to be
stronger because biden's going to let
them be a little bit more loose
and censor whoever they want on the
right so telecom and wireless may not
be too happy with biden because byte may
get in there and want to force them to
lower their prices because for the
longest time you know telecom
and these guys have been going at it
they don't have like 50 competitors
it's just a handful of people that keep
competing for the same margin this guy's
got 21
19 but if he starts going in there
saying your pricing's too high your
pricing is too high your pricing is too
high
they'll have to change costs for phone
for internet for service a lot of that
stuff
so i don't know if it's going to be a
good time for telecommunication the next
two or four years so agriculture is a
little bit technical as well so
first of all you know you know he's not
for oil he's talked about it a lot
fracking oil all that stuff so a lot of
these companies that make those corn
uh or or soy biofuels that is used in
motor fuels that's from agriculture and
farms they're going to take a hit
potentially
but if he opens up the tariffs with
china they can now sell to other places
so that could benefit them and in the
meat packing
companies that are constantly digging
taking shots at them by cory booker
elizabeth warren saying they're feckless
you know they're not responsible
because you know people are working so
closely kind of like amazon all these
guys are working out the place
they may enforce some social distancing
so it's a lot of different things going
on at the same time
some are going to enjoy it some are not
going to enjoy it so energy industry is
also going to be interesting because
there's a lot of different moving parts
with this one too because
on one end he doesn't want oil but at
the same time he wants to go more green
with the whole 1.7 trillion dollars over
10 years
but if they don't have the senate he's
not going to be able to pass a 1.7
trillion dollars over 10 years
so green may do well if they have senate
50 50 because kamala will be voting but
if they don't
they probably can't pass that cannot
pass that so
it's going to help green it's going to
hurt oil
again it's going to be a lot coming down
to whether they're going to have control
over senator or not
all right gold and precious metals this
one's going to be simple because any
time we print more dollar
more money the more we give away
stimulus entitlement programs i'm going
to give away this money here that money
here the more we print
value of gold goes higher so he's
planning on printing a lot of money
over the next two to four years that
means the value of gold gold and
precious metals
should go higher the next two to four
years all right finance
and how to market is going to do first
of all the more money free money we give
away to people short term we do better
it's that simple market's going to get a
boost because people have more money to
spend
short term we're going to look good long
term we're going to be in shambles
you're talking about stagflation
inflation a lot of prices will pay long
term short term
it'll look pretty long term your kids or
grandkids
are going to be paying a lot of taxes
very soon i had venture capital and
private equity this one
you know he's committed to giving 10
billion dollars into the economy to go
by and invest into startups and all this
other stuff so there's going to be some
you know national not nationalized but
government-owned companies that they own
shares in the company so that's going to
be taking place which
if there's going to be anybody want as a
business partner it's probably not the
government
uh as an owner of your company but at
the same time
i think a lot of vcs a lot of private
equity is going to be a little bit
tighter
taxes are going to go up for them some
of them are going to try to sell this
year
some are going to try to time it a lot
of sellers and founders may hang on to
their business or their portfolio
to not sell it soon they'll hang on to
it for four to eight years maybe they'll
sell a percentage
retain more long term but this is going
to get very very technical to private
equity and vcs
on what's going to happen with the new
tax plans especially
if republicans lose senate in georgia
all right so we just talked about
different industries now let's talk
about your next
five moves i'm gonna give you three
additional moves on top of the five
moves
um number one move whatever you're doing
right now whatever industry you're in
right now the first thing you gotta do
is you gotta go meet with your cpa
and don't wait meet with them and ask
questions specifically
how are the dune tax laws going to
affect me but don't wait till 2021
meet with your cpa asap that is your
number one
move number two all the names i gave you
on this cabinet go
study them and find out how progressive
they are because the more progressive
they are
the more taxes are going to go higher
there's going to be a lot of different
changes taking place but don't just kind
of wing it go
study who he's choosing for his cabinet
because it's going to affect you and
your family
do some math and study who's going to be
president in 2024. if biden is president
by 2024 he'll be 82 is he going to run
again on the second term or
if he's not who will be replacing him is
it going to be kamala harris
which leads me to point number four if
biden's going to be 82 we've he's
already going to be the oldest president
we've ever had 78 years old but he'll be
82 years old
can he have the energy to run again for
another eight year four years to be a
president at 86 i don't know
if he decides to step away and kamala is
going to be the president and she
chooses a vp or somebody bumps up to be
the vp
the next thing got to study is what is
kamala harris's policies how far left is
she how progressive is she because if
she becomes a president
and replaces biden you just have to be
prepared if that takes place
are you okay with the policies and
whatever they may be how do you need to
pivot
based on kamala's parish policies so
don't just study biden's policies
you got to study kamala's policies as
well so number five the election matters
a lot don't get me wrong presidency
matters a lot but
this midterm is probably going to be
just as important
as the election that we had so take a
very close look at the midterms because
congress won
and the republicans picked up six seats
democrats picked up five
are they going to keep during the
midterms or will republicans flip more
seats to take over house
and the senate and if that does happen
what can they really pass
it's just going to be an executive you
know uh
what do you call it executive orders
non-stop back to back to back
and he won't be able to pull a lot of
the plans that they want to pull if they
lose
house and senate if the flip side
if they get all three they can do
anything
they want after midterms next if you're
a founder ceo
when you meet with your cpa don't just
ask how the taxes affects you
ask how the taxes affects your investors
ask how the taxes affects your employees
your sales people your clients everybody
that directly or indirectly is doing
business with you because you want to
know where they're at
to also be able to know their strengths
their weaknesses their positioning
so you can help them out so you can
strengthen your partnership with them
whether it's your employees
your sales people your partners or your
vendors so point number seven is the
complete opposite of point number six
if you're an employee or salesperson or
an executive in a company but you're not
a ceo or founder
go study taxes and see how it affects
all of you including your customers
and how it affects your ceo and founder
because if you
study that then you'll be able to say i
can't understand what my boss is going
through right now i may not be in a
position to go out and ask for a big
race because his taxes just went up
let me understand his positioning
because if you go to him he's going to
say
what are you talking about i just have
to give 20 more this year than i paid
last year
we can't do a lot of that stuff right
and my hands are tied behind my back
so go also study taxes on how it affects
your boss and the business owner above
you
point number eight is something i do
every single time something happens in
the market here's what i do i call every
single industry expert i know
here's what the call sounds like hey bob
hey jason hey jack
uh what's going on with the marketplace
what do you mean new president
knew this is there any new regulation
any new legislation anything i need to
be looking out for are
any of the companies i'm working with
affected by this negatively because i
don't want that i don't want any of the
companies i'm working with to be
negative
effectively negatively and they'll say
well here's what's going on this is what
could happen this if elizabeth warren
does this you could face if the part
so i'm gathering intel from everybody by
calling five to seven different people
now i'm informed i take all of that
information that i have
and i have a meeting with my staff to
say this is what we need to look out for
next
here's what could happen here and this
is what we're going to be doing moving
forward and before i give you the free
pdf
uh on everything i've covered with you
here so you can process it for yourself
the whole thing i'm telling you about is
about knowing your next 5 10 15 moves
everything is about your next 5 10 15
moves if you've not yet read the book
your next five moves i wrote this book
it came out three months ago it's
already sold nearly 100 000 copies
if you've not read it it's the number
one wall street journal bestseller
go order because everything about the
way you think in 2020 going into 2021
has to be about your next five 10 15
moves so with that being said if you
want the pdf send us a text title biden
b-i-d-e-n to
one one three two 310-340-11321 again
biden to three one zero
three four zero one one three two we're
gonna send the entire pdf today to you
and if you're out of the country and you
cannot text us go to the link below
subscribe to our newsletter and we will
send you the pdf for free
if you got a lot of value from this
episode today push the thumbs up
and click subscribe to our channel here
thanks for watching everybody take care
bye